[Música]
después de la segunda y definitiva
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
en colombia gustavo petro fue electo
presidente uniéndose a la lista de los
recientes mandatarios en américa latina
que forman parte de una nueva izquierda
de nuestra región vamos a ver entonces
ahora cómo está digamos este mapa
coloreado con los gobiernos de izquierda
en rojo los de centro pues y derecha en
azul y pues ese morado que ustedes ven
allí colombia que estaría en esa
transición porque recordemos que el
presidente y bantú que es un gobierno de
derecha y pasaría entonces a rojo con
esta elección de gustavo petro entonces
vamos a leer un poco este mapa este del
triunfo de petró se suma al de gabriel
boric boris en chile xiomara castró en
honduras al pedro castillo en perú
alberto fernández en argentina y andrés
manuel lópez obrador en mexico y también
sería un gobierno más que izquierda un
poco populista además los líderes
autoritarios de venezuela nicolás maduro
y nicaragua daniel ortega si las cosas
esta nueva tendencia en américa latina
tiene de fondo un momento de
incertidumbre política en el continente
petro es el más reciente y asciende al
poder en medio de una crisis provocada
lo que algunos catalogan como una
debilidad en las instituciones el gaste
el desgaste económico y social que ha
generado esta pandemia de kobe 19 todo
este panorama agravado por los efectos
de la guerra en ucrania y el desinterés
de eeuu por la región que también como
muchos críticos lo dijeron se vio
reflejado en esta reciente cumbre de las
américas saludamos entonces a nuestro
primer invitado del día el sky o mañana
el y consultor político y director de la
asociación brasileña de consultores
políticos cayó gracias por estar
nuevamente con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 un abrazo como lo
veíamos la región asia había
experimentado además una ola de
gobiernos de izquierda a principios del
siglo con representantes como chávez y
lula da silva en brasil en su país en
los kirchner en argentina porque se
reedita esta tendencia de volcar
nuevamente a la izquierda
no te olvides de correr en ecuador
después de los principales gobiernos en
verdad incluso contando con sus
ridículas gestiones para nacionales
no existe un por que
esté involucrado con la idea de
izquierda pero que la es infeliz que
seguimos usando un parámetro
que fue dedicado en la revolución
francesa en 1789
para determinar por las corrientes
políticas en nuestros país primero
porque somos un poco alienígenas y
partes de distintos de lo que es la
institucionalidad y la
el enganche del enganche de la población
en relación a estas tendencias por
ejemplo nosotros acá no tenemos
poblaciones que se puede decir de
izquierda o poblaciones que se puede
decir de derecha como por ejemplo
tenemos en españa en la andalucía
acá fue el vacío del psoe como tenemos
en españa con
como el norte de españa en galicia que
está dominado por el pp
de la misma manera así claro nosotros
tenemos
identificaciones que son resultados de
elecciones
entonces como resultado de elecciones
como líder esto
no lo que se presenta es una necesidad
de cambio pero en especial a la
necesidad de evaluación del ser humano
después es lo que pasa con la gestión
de la crisis sanitaria de la crisis de
salud de nuestros mandatarios entonces
tenemos como ejemplo
chile
con los audios que salieron en medio de
la plan de la gestión de la pandemia
de la mujer de la esposa de pineda
entonces esto esto enseña y expone los
mandatarios
por una casa grande derecha
la unam
a una postura de valoración de la gente
y obviamente
el discurso si estos liderazgos que
llegó ahora y que están más cercanos a
este eje conocido como izquierda es un
discurso que valora mucho más el ser
humano pero de pareja y yo quiero
recalcar se le necesita destacados es la
elección de francia
la primera vicepresidente negra de la
américa latina es importante acordar que
es una mujer negra que tiene hoy
está muy cerca de la silla presidencial
en un país latinoamericano esto no pasa
esto no es así tan fácil
es un hecho histórico
que tengamos una mujer y negra cerca de
la presidencia de un país
latinoamericano el otro país y yo diría
que ella en especial es un hecho acción
importante punto goma en eeuu cayó y
habíamos ahora como usted lo decía de
eeuu y el continente digamos con este
giro de estas de estos presidentes de
izquierda teniendo un poco el mapa de
rojo por ponerle rojo a la izquierda en
nuestra región como serían entonces
estas relaciones con eeuu teniendo en
cuenta lo que ocurrió en la reciente
cumbre de las américas cuando el
presidente yo vice en decidió no invitar
a varios gobiernos que tildó de no
democráticos para esta cumbre de las
américas
es
como dijo lemont existe una campaña para
pinchar a todo lo que quieren llamar de
izquierda
algo como es tanta pájaros quieren
construir una campaña de miedo y se
escuchó esta campaña de miedo por los
whatsapp por las palabras de rodolfo por
los whatsapp giraron en colombia y que
llegaron a varios incluso a mí que yo
soy yo tampoco tampoco quería hablar de
colombia y me llega este tipo de campaña
porque son campañas sucias podríamos
decir yo son campañas con face news que
son campañas que intentan alimentar una
idea de que estos gobernantes son
gobernantes de terror
existe si una crisis humanitaria en
venezuela pero que es un problema de los
venezolanos y de la forma como ellos
manejan su país y eligen su gobierno
existe si una crisis humanitaria de
nicaragua
y que ahí tiene un problema que tiene
mucho más fuerza e importancia de eeuu
que de hecho cualquier fuerza
internacional de izquierda porque ha
financiado ortega más de una vez
entonces lo que bailén tiene que hacer
es abrir puertas a dialogar es mucho más
importante es una manera de influenciar
mucho más efectiva
las viejas estrategias de pegar y soplar
que se usaron en otros momentos o que
así desea porque esto es el deseo de la
élite
conservadora de nuestros países sudacas
esto que queremos queremos mirarnos y
eeuu pegando a maduro pero esto no va a
funcionar
clarito esto no es el camino que
funcionó hasta hoy de hecho